juin 2013 julian assange et ricardo
patino ministre des affaires étrangères
de l'équateur salue la foule massée
devant l'ambassade de londres même si le
réfugié trouve sa situation
inconfortable
ils apprécient le geste de son pays
rotin protection intégrité et liberté
d'expression garantie
cela fait un an que le président rafael
correa lui accorder l'asile
ils avaient fait ensemble une émission
de télévision pour le réseau russe
russia today
bienvenue au club des persécutés lui a
dit le président correa rafael correa
est alors un ami proche d'hugo chavez
s'est fait partie de l'alliance
bolivarienne avec la cuba de raul castro
et la bolivie d'evo morales accorder
l'asile politique à julian assange c'est
un beau pied de nez à l'an pire les
états unis il restera à l'ambassade 30
ans s'il le faut pendant cinq ans le
père de wikileaks gère donc ces
péripéties judiciaires depuis
l'ambassade en toute tranquillité en
2017 rafael correa décide de ne pas se
représenter à la présidence c'est son
vice président lenin moreno qui est élu
la corruption nous combattrons la
corruption promet-il cei maintenant
d'hier et de demain
seillière vise directement rafael correa
qui fait face à des accusations
il se réfugie au pays de son épouse la
belgique pour lénine mort et nos julian
assange continue avec wikileaks
il devient vite un embarras premier
avertissement en mai 2010 est il peut
dire ce qu'il veut
non le permettez par la passe et le cas
de la politique mais il ne peut pas
parler de la politique des pays qui est
encore moins de l'équateur en 2018
ambassades couple internet de julian
assange et impose des restrictions sur
ces visites avec l'aide du célèbre juge
espagnol baltasar garzon
il poursuit le gouvernement équatorien
sur la question de ces conditions de vie
qui se sont détériorées tout comme ses
relations avec le gouvernement
équatorien jusqu'à la rupture
c'est tout à fait en règle ces contrées
de belgique l'ancien président rafael
correa un ligne et accus son successeur
de vouloir se venger
incroyable
ni oui ni non car wikileaks aurait
révélé l'existence de comptes bancaires
occultes au panama du président lenin
moreno jean michel leprince radio canada
montréal